this is good day las vegas
now it is time once again for our pet of
the week courtesy of the animal
foundation john is with us once again
this morning to talk about our good
friend pepper good morning john
good morning john so talk about pepper
for us uh pepper
is 10 years old she is uh 59 pounds
she's a really really sweet dog i know i
say that about all the dogs but she
really is
she's what we call a velcro dog she went
to foster for a little bit came back
um through a foster program and the the
parents let us know that she was
a super velcro dog super great with dogs
super great with kids she doesn't know
what a cat is
so she didn't honor a cat good with
everybody except felines
fair enough i understand that so a
velcro dog
and ready to go into someone's house
right now yes absolutely
good stuff uh also in addition to uh
pepper being
up for adoption let's talk about another
program on the horizon over at the
animal foundation
we have an adoption program called bunny
bonanza we're waiving adoption fees for
all bunnies
through sunday excellent so whether you
want a bunny or maybe a dog like pepper
uh certainly let's find some of these
great animals some great forever homes
john thank you very much for joining us
this morning and pepper will find you a
good home
oh peppa love it if you would like to
adopt
peppa just give the animal foundation a
call later today the number is
702-955-5901
now again because of the coronavirus and
the pandemic you have to make an
appointment
first to meet pepper or any other animal
there we have information available for
you
at eight newsnow dot com